oh well these people came down here to
start trouble caller
and that was our last call this morning
on the topic on if
protesting affects policy
joining us on the phone right now is
kathleen coakley she is the vice
president of exhibition development for
the international spy museum good
morning good morning tell us about the
main purpose of this site
of the website yes the website now if
you go to
excuse me
spymuseum.org is really up as a media
site to uh
allow members of the press to
get the very basic information and and
quite a bit of detail about what this
museum will be
for the general visitor who goes uh he
or she will get the same information
everything from what the topics are
within the museum to what kinds of
objects we display where we are and
located in washington and what will be
available in july opening on july 19
this summer what led to the creation of
this museum well a great need there is
no museum uh dedicated to espionage
washington is
the spy city of the world and now even
more than before i think people need to
understand the absolute uh
mandate for any nation to gather as much
intelligence about the world within
which we all operate
and when you said july 19
how many floors of the museum are going
to exist and what kind of displays will
you be able to see there you will be
able to see
on three floors of the museum exhibits
that are roughly divided into two parts
the first part gives you an introduction
to the world of espionage and that is
allowing you to put yourself in the
shoes of someone who is a spy or who
could be a spy to understand the
training the expertise the skills and
all the gadgets and technology that a
spy would use
in no matter what country or almost no
matter what time period and then after
you've gotten that orientation you move
back throughout history and see how
how spies operated you see
the um world-changing events that have
taken place because of espionage and
intelligence gathering that went on
everything from battles to home
movements to people who you wouldn't
expect to have been spies who did
operate under the cover of another
career and were able to do incredible
things you would think spies you think
things like gadgets and the equipment
they will use will there be an element
of that included in your exhibit
absolutely this is you know i think most
of us know about these gadgets from from
seeing them in in films and tv and the
truth is it's hard to know which came
first the chicken or the egg we know
from our advisors that many of the
intelligence agencies paid very careful
attention to the things that came out of
pop culture because many of the ideas
weren't so far off the mark and vice
versa so you'll see the things that i
mean everything from a lipstick gun that
you could carry in your purse and one of
the ones we have it was based on one
found at the west german border
to
uh really amazing technology for its
time uh due to the needs of breaking
codes in the second world war the very
precursors to the computers were
developed to be able to break codes on a
daily basis and intercept
nazi air force and naval signals is this
museum federally funded in any way no it
isn't it's privately funded we were very
lucky in washington to get the first um
tax increment financing from the d.c
government that was a real coup but we
are a a private museum
that um
will be able to then in the district
view be able to give back we're not
competing for philanthropic funds in
that area and just before we go give
your website address please it is
spymuseum.org
and that is kathleen coakley she's the
vice president of the exhibition
development for the international spy
museum we appreciate your time with us
thank you very much
we've been for the last few weeks on
saturdays taking a look at the history
of u.s intelligence and counter
intelligence joining us now from boston
is peter gross he is the author of
gentleman spy he also wrote this book
operation roll back america's secret war
behind the or iron curtain and he joins
us today to talk about the life and
influence of alan dulles good morning
sir good morning good morning whatever
time of day it is wherever you are
our first question is what was alan
dulles's contribution or biggest
contribution to the us intelligence
service well alan dulles is surely one
of the most
enigmatic and conflicted
personalities of the american 20th
century he was
as the biography i wrote
calls him very much a gentleman a 19th
century figure
yet he was the inspiration
of an american intelligence
establishment a a
an arm of government which was
officially sanctioned to do things which
could not be officially acknowledged he
was not the first he was not the founder
of the cia but he was its inspiration
and long time director and how directly
did he inspire
it as you say
alan dulles started life as a diplomat
but he had he was intrigued by the
things that could be done
under the guise of diplomacy
uh
to influence to promote to encourage
trends in foreign policy
secretly
he believed that not everything had to
be out in the open
and that often things could be done much
more usefully without public
acknowledgement this was a
uh
we take this kind of for granted today
but
at the in the 1940s 50 years ago 60
years ago it was not at all taken for
granted it was a a radical notion with
effects that some would say
have been benign
and others probably many more would say
have been destructive to the american
role uh through the 20th century we can
argue about that how old was alan dulles
when he became director of the cio i'm
sorry how how old was he he was in early
middle age he was born in 1893 so he
would have been in his 50s
already a distinguished public figure
in in government in the law the wall
street law
he was he was a renowned commentator
and thinker on american foreign policy
he also
although
we didn't know it at the time he also
was one of the most successful uh
american intelligence operators during
world war ii in penetrating nazi germany
through his net the network of agents
which he set up from his base in neutral
switzerland we learned about that after
the war obviously we didn't know it
during the war he was a true
professional
in the game
of intelligence uh intelligence
operations
at a time when
there weren't any professionals except
for him
and we are going to be talking about
alan dulles as we continue our look at
the history of u.s intelligence if you'd
like to chime in and offer some comments
and ask peter gross a question about
alan dulles you can call on one of four
lines on your screen
zero for 202-585-3880
two oh two five eight five three eight
eight one for democrats and for all
others two oh two five eight five three
eight eight two we also have a special
line set aside for members of the
intelligence community it's two oh
202-585-3883
at the beginning of his intelligence
career what was alan dulles's first
mission
as a young diplomat
his first assignment was to the united
states embassy in vienna
in uh 1916 world war one was going on he
was the junior third secretary and
shortly after he arrived this is what
makes him such a colorful figure shortly
after he arrived the habsburg emperor
franz joseph died and here was this
young diplomat who represented the
united states at the funeral of the
great habsburg emperor that was his
first mission that's how his
uh career began that's the book end at
the beginning the funeral of the emperor
franz josef
the other bookend at the end of his
career you haven't asked me this yet but
it completes the picture of alan dulles
he served on the warren commission
investigating the assassination of john
f kennedy
from the emperor franz josef to john f
kennedy that was the career of alan
dulles and how long did he serve as cia
director he was cia director through
most of throughout the eisenhower
administration and into the first year
of the kennedy administration he was dci
from 1953 to 1961 a very long time for a
head of central intelligence our first
question this morning is on our line for
democrats good morning go ahead
are you there yes what's your question
for mr gross sir uh mr gross um i'm just
curious as to why
after a spy is caught an american spy is
caught
why is he after he's deprived why why do
we keep him alive
they cost americans so many problems
i was just curious as to why they're not
shot like they are in russia
i'm sorry you mean when the united
states captures a
spy a person who has been
caught in espionage
why they're not shot right away
if the the issue is the united states is
not
the soviet union and we do have the rule
of law and in espionage cases
it's never as clear-cut as you make it
sound uh the united states has executed
spies starting i mean
we can go back to the
to the story of nathan hale uh who
wasn't
it was he wasn't spying for the united
states but
uh
there have been executions but there
have also been uh uh
legal procedures and frequently you say
after they've been debriefed uh
frequently the debriefing has to go on
for many many years because the the
espionage agent can continue to supply
interesting tidbits and useful
information a member of the intelligence
community is next from vienna virginia
go ahead please
yes uh i'm a former marine uh signal
intelligence analyst
and uh i was in a radio reconnaissance
unit in uh in hawaii and and we used to
deploy into the south pacific
and do things down there and i was just
wondering uh the intelligence community
in general
do they go about recruiting
spies
from the military units or do they get
them from the civilian world mostly how
does that work
well uh
first of all they don't recruit spies a
spy is a very loose word covering a
multitude of sins or virtues depending
on where you are
the the preferred word is agents uh
undercover agents agents serving
under diplomatic business
educational cover careers
recruitment by the cia is done
uh not only in the military services in
fact rather less likely in the military
services because the military has its
own intelligence uh branches and
missions which are quite often quite
different from the cia they're recruited
among the population at large among
young people men and women who are uh
interested in some kind of public
service
who don't know probably when they go
into the agency whether they're going to
be
a public overt analyst
or whether they're going to operate
under some kind of cover which takes
many years to build up
you don't apply for a job as a spy
and and uh
you find yourself acting as an
undercover agent only after a long
period of preparation
when mr dulles became the head of the
cia what are some of the first things he
did to establish his own tone in the
department what are the things that he
saw that maybe needed to to be improved
on well even before he became head of
the cia he uh
strongly influenced this new novel
organization uh for for secret
intelligence
he knew
how to set up networks of agents the the
the complicated
filigree of contacts and missions many
of which uh individually seemed petty
but when put together by the man at the
top
it was only men at the top in those days
uh um
add up to a picture
of of information
secretly acquired which can be of use to
policymakers alan dulles knew how to do
this he was one of the few american
public figures or private figures who
knew how to do this and so he had a a
strong influence on the procedures for
acquiring secret information that's how
that remember the united states was
still smarting under the surprise attack
at pearl harbor and we are the the the
national leadership democrat republican
whatever uh didn't want to be caught
red-handed like that again so how do you
avoid uh that kind of surprise attack
well you you find ways of getting
information and who knew better than
alan dulles how to do that our next call
is on our line for others from somerset
new jersey
uh good morning good morning go ahead
please thank you uh yes sir i heard you
mentioned uh that mr dulles served under
the eisenhower administration uh being
somewhat of a person into history i
believe the eigenhour administrator
during the eisenhower administration the
cia was one of the most embarrassing
things america had to offer considering
what he did to fidel castro who was
quoting thomas jefferson until mr dalton
cia thought about invading cuba and
tried to do it and pushed castro to
russia uh i believe you were involved in
the philippines where a democratically
elected president was overthrown that
country is still smarting from that
effort uh to this day and i also believe
the cia had a lot to do with purchase
the moment we know that country is still
smarting and still on his knees as a
result of someone that you're giving a
whole lot of accolades to it i i just
don't see
where he deserves it
that's a very fair commentary the and by
accolades i'm uh i'm talking about him
as a professional of intelligence under
his leadership uh the united states
government suffered many embarrassments
the one perhaps most striking which you
did not mention was the uh the shooting
down of a u2 spy plane which uh
president eisenhower uh stood up before
the world and denied
a few days later the president of the
united states was shown and uh revealed
in an outright lie this was the fault of
the cia this was under alan dallas's
leadership
the you could have mentioned the cia
operations in iran in 1953 the overthrow
of uh masadek uh with implications that
we still are suffering through the
uh an attempted coup in guatemala in
1954
throwing out the legally elected
president our benz
again the implications of cia meddling
in in third world countries still
continues the bay of pig operations not
under eisenhower instantly but under
john kennedy was definitely
on the watch of alan dulles and he uh
stepped down shortly thereafter it was
an american disaster it was an american
it was a cia disaster
uh
the record is by no means uh
pure and and clean
how was he perceived as a leader
the the most
the hardest thing when i was writing his
biography the hardest thing about alan
dulles was to convey
uh
the complex nature of his
character and his personality uh
enigmatic
uh secretive in what he was doing
he was one of the most colorful and
genial uh
people of his time
remember alan dulles was the younger
brother there was the older brother john
foster dulles who was much more famous
uh a towering stature in his day he was
the secretary of state all-powerful
secretary of state for eisenhower
he was a very austere and uh distant
figure
not particularly uh beloved
by the public at large alan dulles the
younger brother
he was cheerful genial always ready with
quips and colorful comments
one of the people who i had discussed
his biography with as i was writing it
summed up the two brothers
john foster dulles
many people who agreed with him still
didn't like him
alan dulles most people who didn't agree
with him could not help but like him
so as a leader there is no doubt that he
gen
generated immense loyalty which still
exists within the intelligence community
a member of the intelligence community
calling in from quaker quakertown
pennsylvania good morning
good morning
uh ahead
hello sir are you there go ahead
we've lost him hello
hello go ahead
denver colorado is next on our line for
republicans good morning good morning go
ahead uh i look forward to uh purchasing
mr grouse's book today as a matter of
fact it sounds very interesting
uh let me just uh
ask him a few questions i i realize
a good spy like a
a wise internist doesn't ever tell all
he knows
but i thought vienna was the spy capital
of the world uh or is that just a
throwback to the second world war
and secondly
uh since i have you on the line
it wouldn't it be nice if the
intelligence community community could
figure some way
of
identifying cars the stolen cars
take and of course this is a detail that
probably most people aren't terribly
interested in
but so that the car could be identified
as across the border back into mexico
when they were when they were stolen
and that could be a satellite project
but
anyway i
look forward to hearing your discussion
and thanks very much
well thank you for those comments uh
there are probably a lot of cities
around the world which would vie for the
title of spy capital of the world uh
either buy for it or run away from it
lisbon
uh
switzer bayern switzerland berlin
as the as world politics have changed so
have the the places where intelligence
agents meet and and uh
do their dirty tricks
um
you know the the uh
the techniques
of acquiring information
change with uh with the times with the
sorts of information that are required
some things now can be done by
electronic eavesdropping by
satellite
photographs or other sensing devices
there's still a lot of things however
the intentions of people which cannot be
discerned electronically and it is
necessary to have human contacts the the
the human agent which is what alan
dulles knew in world war ii
uh remains a vital figure in
intelligence
st thomas virgin island is next go ahead
please yes good morning
to you and to your guest
i attended pennsylvania state university
in the mid-50s before
alan dulles became director of cia was
he not in a position of leadership
president of the university there or
had some association with the
pennsylvania state university in the 50s
mr gross hello excuse me yes are you
there yes i'm here yeah his career was
never in academia he was a wall street
lawyer he was a partner in the firm of
sullivan and cromwell
after he stopped after he resigned from
the american foreign service he was a a
pillar of the american legal
establishment and a leader of the
council on foreign relations
he did not have any academic career
though he was widely respected in
academic circles
when he took head of the cia you talked
about some of the low points of the
the the organization under his
leadership what were some of the high
points
you know anything i say
i'm going to be jumped on
because what
one man's high point is another man's
low point
i think it would have to be said
that the
the
lasting legacy of aledales
beyond any specific
uh operation
was the creation
of a responsible
more or less depending on the time and
the circumstances
government agency where none existed
before
a
an organization
responsible
to the political leadership it never
when it never went off on its own like a
rogue elephant
uh for very long there were individual
cases and they were promptly dealt with
the notion of the cia as a
secret government or as a rogue elephant
really is not borne out by by the
histories that we can now see as
documents are released the political
leadership
first harry truman and the truman
administration where it all got started
remember
then eisenhower and his administration
kennedy etc etc the political leadership
has always
called the tune for what the agency
would do
if sometimes enthusiasts within the
agency tried to
to get away with something as they did
they were
dealt with
with relative promptness i think alan
dulles has to be given the credit
for
establishing
that tradition of responsible
uh
relatively competent
actions and mechanisms to carry out
government policy glenn allen virginia
on our line for republicans good morning
go ahead please yes thank you
when i went to school there were a bunch
of hungarian freedom fighters there too
and they were promised by the cia that
they would get support in their fight
against the soviet union when they ride
tried to retake hungary they were
shooting machine guns off the roofs and
things like that
obviously it went down quite sour and
they were lucky to escape with their
lives thank you
this uh 1956 episode is certainly one of
the most controversial
uh and
uh
troubling
episodes in american intelligence
history
it is not as clear-cut as
you just described it or indeed as
hungarian freedom fighters perceived it
the documentary evidence is clear
that the united states government did
not promise military or other
military or that kind of political
support to this rebellion
enthusiasts in the field who were radio
announcers and who were suddenly given
microphones and were able to talk
without discipline
may indeed have given the perception
that
american tanks were waiting to come in
which was never true
many inquiries took place by several
different governments including the the
german government where these radio
stations were were located
these inquiries took place after the uh
the the the 1956 uprising
and uh the
although the cia admitted lacks
discipline
among some of its outlying
spokespeople announcers
usually emigrates themselves from
hungary the record is clear that
the cia
did not
instigate
or promise to
promote
this uprising this was a heroic uprising
of hungarian people themselves
frankly at that time
perhaps even now the cia
does not have the competence
to run that kind of show this was a
hungarian operation of which uh
modern-day hungary should be very proud
englewood california on our line for
others good morning go ahead
yeah good morning thanks for c-span i'm
curious you you were talking about about
how he
where did he get his training where
where did he get his ideas for for
becoming a spy you implied that he just
knew it he had training who were his
heroes this is a this is a really good
question because um
remember alan dulles younger son of
adore presbyterian minister in upstate
new york
um
a diplomat in the family tradition his
father was a minister but his uncle was
a diplomat secretary of state for
president wilson
the diplomatic service seemed the right
thing for him to do and he was
interested in people in in
[Music]
mixing with people that was always his
his special talent
how did he learn
there was no one to teach him in world
war one uh
intelligence was such a primitive
operation and no one knew how to do it
dulles
picked it up talk about on-the-job
training there's one
you know anecdotes incidents taught him
lessons and one of the most famous if
if i can have a couple of minutes
because this is one of the most famous
aladella stories
there he was a young diplomat by this
time he was in barron switzerland 1917
and he was the junior it was easter
sunday he was the junior man on the
staff so when a caller an unknown caller
called into the embassy he was the one
who had to take the call a heavy foreign
voice said i must speak to someone at
the united states embassy right away it
was sunday dulles wanted to play tennis
with a girlfriend he said no no no i'm
sorry the embassy is closed we're not
available the voice insisted no no it is
important that we speak i won't try to
imitate the foreign accent and dulles
said well if it's so important
i'll come in on monday when the embassy
will be open and the voice said no no
monday is too late
it's too late and uh the dulles hung up
the phone never pursued it
on monday
the caller whose name was
vladimir ilyich lenin
got on a train and went to petrograd to
begin the bolshevik revolution and
because of his girlfriend and his tennis
game alan dulles had muffed the
opportunity for a face-to-face talk with
lennon
dulles would tell this story about
himself many times especially to new
recruits into the agency with the lesson
which he learned you asked how did he
learn to do these things
he learned
always be available to people do not
slam the door on anyone because you
never know who is going to be
useful or interesting or valuable for
what you are trying to achieve that's
one of the lessons
new york city on our line for democrats
hello go ahead
um two questions one is uh have you read
the book the second oldest profession by
philip knightley yes indeed i
take away from that book that the whole
enterprise of spying is a complete waste
of time and money because the whole
system is fatally flawed in the sense
that there's no way that any outsider
has of telling whether they're
getting information which is useful or
not
and another example of the fatally slide
nature of the system is the fact that
every time they make a mistake they
always argue because it's because they
didn't have enough uh in the way of
resources so it basically the worse they
are the more resources they're able to
garner and um certainly the kinds of
things you've been talking about so far
this morning
are much more along the lines of their
failures than successes so
i'd like to i'd like you to discuss a
little bit about
why you think spying is useful at all my
second question is with regard to kim
roosevelt's retrospective book on the
mosadek uh overthrow in 1953 in iran
which i believe was written in the early
1980s i've also recently read that it
strikes me that there is a complete lack
of insight in any kind of
learning experience that went on in that
book between the time of the overthrow
in 1953 and the time the book was
written several decades later thank you
um
i think it is a vast overstatement to
say that espionage is fatally flawed
uh espionage
intelligence gathering is not a
a science it is an art
there are mistakes made it isn't perfect
but that is a a great jump from saying
it's fatally flawed
um
the acquisition of secret intelligence
uh cannot be 100 percent accurate and
there will be mistakes there are
mistakes
they're widely known
uh that doesn't mean however it is uh uh
not worth the effort there have been
successes there have been
american agents placed in critical
positions inside the kremlin inside the
soviet government the united states
policy makers learned a great deal about
soviet
military and nuclear capabilities from
human agents which they would not have
known had there been no
organized intelligence service
incidentally
i have to tell you the uh a wonderful
impish french
of course intelligence chief
once uh strongly criticized to me the
notion of intelligence as the second
oldest profession
he said
it is
the first oldest profession because
before you can
go to the place for the other thing you
have to know the address and the
telephone number only the french could
come up with that analysis
as for kim roosevelt's views and his
learning experiences i can say let me
say two things that spy memoirs
intelligence
memoirs are
like
other memoirs of public and private
figures notoriously selective in what
they say in how they people remember
things exactly the way they want to
remember things so
none of these memoirs can be taken as a
factual gospel
i do think there is a learning
experience that kim roosevelt however
went through and it it happened very
quickly kim roosevelt was one of uh alan
dulles's
leading
undercover operatives and indeed he was
uh the key
uh
covert agent who engineered the
overthrow of mussodek in iran in 1953
a year later when the cia when dulles
and the eisenhower administration wanted
to overthrow our bens in guatemala
half a world away
dulles turned to kim roosevelt and said
hey can can you pull the same thing
and roosevelt flatly refused saying
guatemala is not iran
uh the situations are completely
different you cannot run the kind of
operation in guatemala that we ran in
iran and no i won't do it
turned him down flatly
so other people were
given the job so i do think we have to
give some people credit
alan dulles on down for learning from
their experience we are talking with
peter grossi is the author of several
books including gentlemen spy the life
of olin dulles a couple of weeks ago we
talked about the head of the oss william
donovan describe the relationship
between jonathan and dulles
donovan
was
dulles first
boss so to speak in intelligence in in
civilian intelligence and it was donovan
who hired dulles
dulles worked for him
loyally throughout the war
it quickly became apparent however
that dulles
knew a great deal more
about
how to
manage intelligence
than donovan did
donovan knew a lot about bureaucratic
politics which dulles wasn't very good
at uh donovan knew how to maneuver and
my goodness did he ever have to maneuver
between conflicting interests in in
washington between military civilian
political
uh personnel personality you you went
into all that um
dulles was very bad on bureaucratic
infighting but as i said before he was
such a genial figure that it was very
hard for even his enemies in the
military intelligence services to to to
stay angry with him for very long
after the war donovan was
unceremoniously uh ousted by harry
truman the oss was abolished
and
but a few years later when truman
realized that he'd made a mistake and
that we needed an intelligence service
he turned uh more to dulles than he did
to donovan uh for i think dulles was
younger and and also he recognized the
talent uh uh donovan
probably looked upon alan dulles as an
ingrate uh and donovan probably wanted
to be the head of the new c.i.a
but it was not to be so in the last
years the the mentor and protege
relationship had had frayed albuquerque
new mexico up next on our line for
republicans go good morning go ahead
good morning good morning mr gross i
have two questions for you they're kind
of like little tidbits if you will
the first question is
do agents
from separate companies account
companies
countries
know each other and the reason i ask
that question
is that of course everything will go
nameless but i
have a friend that i talked to that was
a foreign agent
overseas and there was a russian agent
whose
children child was very very ill and
they didn't have the pharmaceuticals
in russia
and our agent so he told me and this is
the only story i ever got out of him he
wouldn't tell me anything else
our agent actually whose cover was in
the pharmaceutical industry
got the russian agent the medication
necessary to save his child's life
so that the the james bond cloak and
dagger guys going around shooting each
other certainly is uh
is not that image as far as that story
is concerned
and the second question is
how did you go about researching your
book uh
to get all the information that you know
you had to get to to publish it that's a
very nice story which i had not heard
before but it is completely believable
um
uh
it's one of the ironies yes there is
kind of a
comradeship among
agents not all of them of course
agents of
friendly and enemy powers sometimes do
know each other
they may not know exactly who the other
person is or they certainly won't know
exactly what the other person's mission
is
but
they share
common tensions pressures demands
and in rare cases it might be that there
would be that kind of
comradeship and i like that story very
much
researching the book of alan dulles and
the the the later book on operation
rollback
um was a challenge because the freedom
of information act
goes only so far when you're dealing
with secret intelligence
diplomatic archives may be
largely opened but intelligence archives
are very heavily
censored in some cases uh in most cases
frankly operational documents are
destroyed uh only two or three years
later not because
any they might have some political
significance but just in the normal
routine they're shredded so the the
files are not complete
um
a lot of alan dulles's career
was outside intelligence and that was uh
fascinating to to talk with members of
his family and his associates
i actually
i met i did meet alan dulles i was a
school boy at the time and he was the
director of central intelligence so it
was hardly a a uh
a fruitful interview but um there were
plenty of other uh people around who
could share their memories of him when
it comes to the actual political and uh
intelligence operations it was a process
of triangulation
you had the memories of
of retired agents like kim roosevelt and
other people which were
sometimes reliable sometimes not
reliable you had memories of other
people that you could match with that
you had policy documents some of them
from the state department more
interesting from the national security
council from the white house itself
you could piece these things together
and
i made the rule with uh that as i was
researching the book
that um
that i would not report any incident any
episode which came from only one source
this is a fairly standard rule of
journalists and it should be of
historians
uh there had to be more than one source
and frequently uh to my sorrow even now
there were some episodes that i just
could not put in the book because i
could not confirm them to that level of
reliability this is the cover of the
book gentlemen spy the life of alan
dulles he has also written operation
roll back america's secret war behind
the iron curtain was mr dulles married
oh yes
married
married just once
to a very gracious lady named clover
who
had absolutely nothing to do with the
intelligence side of his life
uh it has to be said dulles was a very
convivial and uh um charming uh
philanderer he also had several
mistresses who were known to his wife
and in at least one case wife and
mistress became
closest lifelong friends
uh this was an a kind of
interesting
edwardian side to allen dulles's
character mary brandcroft is the
mistress you're talking about mary
bancroft is one of them and she is the
one who became uh clover dulles's
lifelong friend this was
during world war ii clover was in new
york at home alan was in the field in
switzerland and mary bancroft was his uh
very gung-ho very able uh kind of
assistant who they would work together
on on running their intelligence
networks and they worked very well
together atlanta georgia on our line for
others good morning go ahead please
atlanta are you there yes sir good
morning uh
i had my question answered about the oss
earlier
but i still would like to ask what was
the principle area
of research
and in what
library and what government agencies did
dr gross do his uh work
i'll hang up and listen thank you
all over the place um
dulles his own personal papers are at
princeton
uh along with his brothers john foster
uh alan dulles's personal papers are are
very interesting letters of
busy man but absolutely nothing about
intelligence he
quite properly did not take any of his
office files home
the cia itself
a significant amount of information in
declassified documents and in subsequent
analyses which they were which were
written in-house
and
of course carefully classified but they
were willing to declassify them for me
with all sorts of uh
deletions some of which were so um
silly and petty that it was easy to
understand what was behind the black
marks you didn't need any great skill in
cryptography to to figure out what they
were saying
uh the state department
as i said the eisenhower library and the
records of the national security council
were particularly valuable because of
course
dulles did operate at a high policy
level
um
interviewing people uh who knew dulles
or who had retired from the cia
there were a large number of sources i i
list them in the uh acknowledgements of
gentleman spy and i think it goes over
two pages if i remember correctly a
large number of people were were happy
to help
uh some of
whom were willing most of whom were
willing to be named a few still
preferred not to have their names used
um
many were credible to a large extent no
one was a hundred percent credible they
never are in in any kind of writing of
history you don't get 100 percent
credibility and precision
uh this is the role of the historian to
make judgments to analyze and the record
is always
alive and ready to be corrected
our next call omaha nebraska on our line
for democrats hello go ahead yes my name
is joyce sutton my husband was a cic
agent during the second world war and i
never hear it talked about much i would
like to say that i was around the young
the men a number of times they loved to
talk about their uh when they had to
write the reports to washington that
seemed to be on their minds a lot it was
so important but what i wanted to
mention about a successful operation
my husband was stationed at alamogordo
but
there were planes being
brought down crashing during the second
world war and they about a week they
halted all the planes flying out of
america
and he along with
one of the
engineers
there on the base in alamogordo
i believe they probably el paso he was
he went down to el paso
discovered that there was some sticky
substance on the outside of the motor
and finally they
they figured out it had to do with
using either oil or gas from two
different companies and that's what
caused that crash
so the push was interesting though and
disturbing to me
he was stationed then in tucson
the same thing happened again
why wasn't that sent out immediately
to all the places it should have been
sent out to
you you've raised a very important point
about the nature of intelligence
the many levels of information and
assessment of that information cic of
course was a military intelligence
service counterintelligence corps
cia and allen ellis was a civilian
service and um
the type of information
required or or the the the the the
sought
by different intelligence services the
type of information is very different uh
you mentioned that interesting example
about the the um uh the the oil on the
surface of the planes this is a fine
example of highly technical information
which is extremely important
to certain people who are tasked with
dealing with that kind of
issue
but
frankly not at all important to a
secretary of state or a president of the
united states except in its uh possible
implications
intelligence is very fragmented
there are certain agencies certain
bureaus uh charged and we have to
include the fbi in this charged with
doing certain things with observing
certain things there are other agencies
uh
alan dulles's agency the cia foremost
among them which operate on more of a
policy level
and
their mission
is to figure out
what the leaders in the kremlin
are going to do
now
uh
in caricature form uh or in beijing or
in in tehran or in wherever
these are policy questions
the answers are built up from a whole
range of other things
but uh
that is the kind of issue that allen
dulles would be involved in as to why
the specific technical intelligence that
you mentioned was not widely
disseminated
this is known as the the uh static
factor that so much information comes in
this was the problem at pearl harbor in
1941 long before so much
bitsy fragmentary information comes in
it is a superhuman task to
sort out wheat from chaff to figure out
how they fit together and to
draw a conclusion from these little bits
and pieces of information which can be
meaningful to a political leadership
which has to make a decision
newark delaware on our line for others
hello you're on with peter gross good
morning gentlemen um i had a question
about um
alan dulles's posting in 1945 in uh
occupied berlin
and his oversight of the white list and
the compilation of those i'm sorry his
oversight of what the white list okay
and um just dealing with uh people such
as carl blessing who uh initially after
the war uh alan dulles helped to
cultivate
a uh kind of a story that he was an
anti-nazi when indeed it turns out later
that he was a part a member of the nazi
party as early as 1937. and that's just
wondering as does a man like alan dulles
towards the end of his career kind of
look back on things that he may have
thought at the time were right and it's
you know at the end of his career you
may have said well you know
certain people or certain things i did
maybe weren't the right thing to do or
the right people to deal with does a man
like that have those kind of thoughts or
does he just
at the time you know just
figure that he did what he had to do and
no regrets
don't we all
don't we all
look back and say gosh
if i had known then what i know now i
wouldn't have done it that way
but
uh
then there are other people who who just
shrug their shoulders and say i did the
best i could at the time i did it harry
truman was one of those
uh
it doesn't it
there's no
sense in in
beating your breast over mistakes that
you made when you made them at the time
for the best of reasons
alan dulles's work in germany after the
war was indeed as conflicted as you
described
there were
quite a few people who had been i let's
say half a dozen or more who had been
germans
who had been extremely helpful to the
united states intelligence service
under the nazi regime
a few of them may have been nazi party
members
uh what do you do
with a person like this after the war
um
technically
they
had committed treason
against the government of the day
it happened to be hitler's government
and there are many people who would say
of all governments to be to commit
treason against that's a pretty good
candidate nonetheless
uh they had committed treasonable acts
so
what do you do do you try to
do you ignore them do you just dismiss
them all saying their nazis forget them
do you ignore the useful services that
they performed alan dulles did not he
tried to help individuals who
some of whom may have been
quite worthy people others may have been
crass opportunists
there are no rules in this dulles was
very conflicted about a number of these
men
uh he was not at all conflicted about
their
families their wives and and children
and he used every resource he could lay
his hands on to help those people in the
difficult years after the war uh
reestablish their lives mr oh i'm sorry
how many children did uh alan dulles
have allen dulles had three children uh
uh two daughters and a son uh
none of whom were in any way involved in
his intelligence work he kept his his
life very
carefully compartmented his children
did not know what dad was doing and his
son allen had an incident in the korean
war
his son alan was a marine in the korean
war and was
was
hit by a mortar fire and suffered a very
serious concussion uh with
long-lasting brain damage how did that
affect mr dallas hey he was you know
shattered and he he
what father couldn't be and uh
he he's in his later years he
he
he and clover his wife had great anguish
in in trying to
find the
the right kind of medical and
psychiatric treatment for young allen
who is alive today
west palm beach florida go ahead please
hi
i was wondering especially about the
period in 1945 in germany
whether alan dulles was aware of
eisenhower's
was aware and involved in eisenhower's
policy
of mass murder of
german war prisoners it's estimated one
million may have perished in our
in our camps
no i think there's a little bit of a mix
up here of
what you might be referring to is the
repatriation of prisoners of war to
eastern europe which was agreed upon at
yalta
as a gesture to stalin to the soviet
union that any soviet citizens
who were captured and fell into allied
camps
at the during and at the end of the war
were to be repatriated to the red army
from whence they came
and uh this
this was where
uh
although the american government did not
understand it at the start this was
where these repetiti these prisoners uh
were indeed executed by the communists
uh the american
officers in the field were were
horrified as they saw what was happening
and they tried to stop the post the
process
and eventually it did stop but too late
for the many millions who were
repatriated by franklin d roosevelt's
agreement with joseph stalin
with tragic consequences
when did alan dulles leave the cia 1961
after the uh
the failure of the bay of pear the bay
pig
peaks operation
when a cia
force
thought they could overthrow fidel
castro
it was a ghastly blunder with
implications that still remain
alan dulles took the blame for it all
although he was by no means the
instigator it was on his watch he took
the blame and was very graciously
retired by president kennedy with whom
he remained on very close personal terms
and for the next uh
eight years of his life he
was a public figure he wrote extensively
he gave lectures
and then as i said he finally
served as a distinguished elder
statesman on the warren commission to
investigate kennedy's assassination
conway south carolina is next go ahead
please hi good morning gentlemen
um there are two points about the
intelligence community that i never hear
mentioned
one is the connection
that
reverend moon of the unification church
who owns the washington times the united
press international had strong
intelligence background with this
cia
in connections with the cia
since the 50s or 60s
and the other is that when hanson was
first reported as a russian spy
in 91
by his brother-in-law
to the fbi and then in 92
he was reported by russia
to
president bush
he was they were informed that he was a
spy
and yet
the first president bush decided to keep
him on
now when you connected to the fact that
throughout the eight years of clinton
hansen was this fbi
source that reporters like robert novak
and other
people on the right used to
put in their articles
some
something that it would implicate
that fbi sources have told me that they
are looking at this about clinton or
they're looking like that about janet
reno and yet this man was here to
disrupt our our government
and it and then
surprisingly right before
um right when george w bush takes office
he's captured and then
his he
he's not given the death penalty instead
his wife is given his pension
so it seems to me that if you connect
all of these things
it just doesn't bode well for the bush
family and how they
control
how you know what the public hears
caller thank you
i i don't uh i can
confirm or deny the accuracy of anything
you've just said uh specifically about
hansen or or reverend moon or anybody
else uh what i can say is this however
you're dealing
in a very in a world of ambiguity
with large gray areas
and information
intelligence like
hanson was a soviet spy
uh that reverend moon worked for the cia
the
that information never comes that
specifically
uh there are allegations
a person may be up to no good
these allegations may be true
or untrue
alan dulles himself used to say
look i'm dealing
with
useful people
who for whom i will not vouch
concerning every aspect of their lives
the people i deal with
are not archbishops a rather ironic
comment to be made today
he knew
alan dulles appreciated the
moral gray areas
i can tell you this however
that alger hiss
who was as you know on
[Music]
the center of great political
controversy in the early 1950s know
that uh president roosevelt was himself
tipped off in 1944 that this young
promising young diplomat alger hiss
may have been working too closely with
communist representatives and roosevelt
ignored the information it was it was
one of the
pieces of gossip there was no proof
there was no evidence uh you get
allegations
all the time from
from over enthusiastic co-workers from
bureaucratic enemies from personal
enemies
it
it it's no good to say
the information was available in such
and such a day of 1919 whatever it is
why didn't we act on it it was too
obscure to be credible
in many cases
and our last call this morning on this
topic is from new york city on our line
for republicans go ahead
yes good morning c-span um look we're
talking my name is brian i'm from the
inward section of manhattan we're
talking about infiltrators and spies i
just want to let c-span know brian lamb
i hope is listening uh you have a
screener that answers the phone and in
the last three months or so i've called
this my third call the only time i got
true
this screener did not ask me what my
comment was but there's a male screener
that you have that asked me what my
comment was the first time and says
thanks for passing along it was a
conservative point of view okay now that
we got your chance to talk to us we're
rolling out we're running out of time
what's your question my question is uh
we know that during the 60s the peace
movement was infiltrated by communists
by marxists and they basically led
the peace movement in the 60s we know
that during ronald reagan's era that
there were many uh communist front
groups that stood up for uh daniel
o'teger and nicaragua and we know that
people like brian becker an earlier
gentleman who's associated with the
communist party usa
is also part of this so-called peace
movement and i'd like to ask your guest
there how uh how
how serious is this uh these
infiltrations of communists in these
so-called peace movements you know i'll
have to be quick i understand i would
make the same reaction to your question
that i did to the caricature of the cia
as being all powerful and uh all capable
i think you are giving too much credit
to
the expertise the skill of communist
infiltrators to think that they could
have engineered the whole peace movement
just as people give too much credit to
the cia that they could have engineered
the hungarian revolution or whatever
peter gross is the author of gentleman
spy the life of alan dulles he has
several other books on the topic and
he's joined us in our continuing series
on the history of u.s intelligence mr
gross thank you thank you i've enjoyed
talking with your guests
coming up tomorrow on washington journal
javier den he is the assistant attorney
general of office of legal policy at the
justice department he will be discussing
victims rights we will be also joined in
our 9 to 10 hour by lincoln kaplan he's
the editor and president of legal
affairs and david tell he is the opinion
editor of the weekly standard and they
will be participating in a roundtable
discussion of news for the day have a
good day we'll see you then
[Music]
you're watching c-span brought to you as
a public service by the nation's cable
television industry
here's what's ahead a segment from this
more